l'ennui pas dans un petit peu maintenant
oui parlons de l'ennui à travers les
archives de la télé française
d'abord une définition simple avec un
médecin et félicie nous explique ce
qu'est l'ennui en 1985
l'ennui est vraiment quelque chose de
vécu au plan intellectuel
bon c'est une sorte de vide mais c'est
pas n'importe quel vide parce qu'on peut
être vidé bien mais c'est un vide
douloureux l'ennui c'est une émotion et
au même titre que l'amour ou la
tristesse
elle inspire la littérature comme
l'italien alberto moravia en 1960 et son
roman titre et l'ennui à écouter
l'auteur ce sentiment est renforcé par
l'époque c'est le mal moderne je pense
que tout dans dans le monde qui est est
de réaliser il revendait du style
moderne partout partout il pas tout il
ya la situation industrielle et la llena
ce qu'on appelle aliénation
technologique
c'est à dire l'aliénation dû au fait que
l'on vit au milieu des machines qui
n'est plus en contact la nature et qui
est il est employé comme moyen pays
n'est pas un but presque 30 ans plus
tard en 1988
marguerite duras projette dans le temps
elle imagine l'année 2000 est selon
l'auteur cette époque sera celle de
l'ennui toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que l'ennui soit vécue dans
sa plénitude
tony profond l'ennui pour certains c'est
l'évocation de souvenirs d'école
déshérence en classe que racontent des
personnalités en 2003 on est tout le
temps et j'ai cessé de m'ennuyer quand
quand j'ai commencé à déconner puisque
la déconnade c'est comme un grand remède
à l'ennui
j'espère qu'on va trouver des solutions
a commencé par mettre des profs marrant
l'ennui à l'école l'enduit au travail
dans l'ue dans le couple l'ennui à la
maison la nuit partout mais comme le
disait l'auteur jules renard
la vie est courte mais l'ennui la longue
[Musique]